mais c'est pas possible ah mais my god
les mailles de des dents des rats c'est
plus dur que le plomb ils sont capables
d'apprendre plein de choses différentes
y compris de conduire une petite voiture
est
[Musique]
le rat a une image négative parce qu'il
est souvent associé d'une part à la
maladie il est associé également à la
famille puisqu'il va avoir tendance à
détruire les récoltes en mangeant les
graines et il est également associé à la
saleté puisque c'est un animal qu'on
trouve dans les égouts et dans les
sous-sols mais c'est pas le cas dans
d'autres cultures déjà dans certains
pays on mange les rats en ragoût ou en
brochettes et par exemple en Chine le
rat est plutôt symbole d'ambition et de
charme voir d'abondance au Japon il est
plutôt synonyme de chance et dans la
culture hindouiste le rat est synonyme
de sagesse
contrairement à ce qu'on pense un rap
passe beaucoup de temps dans la journée
à se nettoyer le pelage et d'ailleurs un
sien rat n'est pas propre sur lui c'est
que soit il est malade soit il est très
stressé
les rats peuvent transmettre certaines
maladies à l'humain on peut parler
notamment de la leptospirose ou encore
la fièvre de la morsure du rat qui est
transmise comme son nom l'indique par la
morsure d'un rat
c'est un animal qui a plutôt tendance à
fuir l'homme quand il n'est pas
domestiqué mais par contre dans
certaines conditions particulières où il
peut être surpris par exemple stressé ou
acculer dans certains endroits alors là
il peut se montrer agressif envers
l'homme
on utilise 250 à 200 000 par an en
France c'est un espèce de mammifère
qu'un génome qui est assez proche de
celui de l'homme finalement il est très
facile à élever il coûte peu cher il se
reproduit très vite il présente des
capacités cognitives qui sont finalement
assez proches de celles de l'homme qui
en font donc un bon modèle notamment
pour les études en neurosciences
puisqu'on est capable d'étudier la
mémoire l'empathie les comportements
moteurs le faction sur ces animaux ou
encore l'impact de certaines maladies
neurodégénératives sur ses capacités
notamment dans le cas où on peut pas se
passer de l'animal pour certaines
expériences on fait particulièrement
attention au bien-être de l'animal qui
est évalué tout au long des expériences
ils ont des comportements olfactifs
complexes ils ont des capacités de
mémoire très importante y compris de
mémoire à long terme ils sont capables
d'apprendre plein de choses différentes
y compris de conduire une petite voiture
est il y a même certains rats qui
présentent des capacités des
comportements complexes en utilisant un
écran tactile ils apprennent très vite
qu'il faut qu'ils aillent toucher
l'écran pour obtenir une récompense et
puis ensuite ils sont capables de
détecter une croix d'un triangle voir
même des images plus complexes que ça
ils ont besoin de se souvenir d'où
provient leur nourriture est-ce que
certains endroits sont à risque donc
finalement ces capacités cognitives
elles leur permettent notamment de
survivre dans leur environnement
ça lui sert pour son équilibre
c'est-à-dire que ça fait balancier quand
il va se déplacer notamment sur des
poutres ou des fils un peu ténus sa
queue a également une fonction de
régulation de sa température parce que
c'est un organe où il y a beaucoup de
vaisseaux sanguins
on trouve pas les rats que dans les
villes mais on les trouve principalement
dans les villes parce que ils y trouvent
un environnement favorable déjà il y a
un accès facilité à la nourriture par
tout ce qui est déchets de l'être humain
et il y trouve de nombreuses cachettes
et en fait le moment où on les voit
c'est souvent les moments où il y a des
conditions qui deviennent défavorables
pour eux donc par exemple on peut penser
leur d'inondations ils ont tendance à
sortir en plein jour parce que leur
terrier sont inondés et s'ils ont pas
trop accès à la nourriture alors ils
vont remonter plutôt en surface et là on
va avoir beaucoup là où il y a beaucoup
de nourriture ou de déchets qui
s'accumulent donc ça veut pas forcément
dire qu'il prolifèrent c'est juste qu'on
les voit plus
on mangeait un peu de tout donc compris
des cadavres d'ailleurs des fruits des
légumes des sandwichs des restes de
viande des restes de pâtisserie il
raffole de toute la nourriture humaine
que ils peuvent trouver
ces incisives donc les deux dents de
devant poussent en continu donc c'est un
animal qui a besoin de ronger en
permanence des choses pour les user et
les mailles des dents des rats une
dureté de 5,5 sur l'échelle de Moss
c'est-à-dire que c'est plus dur que le
plomb que l'aluminium que le cuivre et
c'est pour ça que en fait ils rongent
tout ce qui trouve tout ce qui leur
passe sous les dents donc ça peut être
des fils électriques ça peut être du
bois ou même de l'asphalte rongé ça les
déstresse beaucoup
il faut essayer qu'il n'est pas accès à
cette nourriture et limiter ou éviter
les points d'accès dans son logement
donc évitez les trous qui permettent à
un rongeur de passer après c'est une
espèce qui est très curieuse donc il va
avoir tendance à vouloir explorer son
environnement donc c'est possible que un
rapace par chez vous mais ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'il va s'y installer
mais si les conditions sont favorables
ils risquent de s'y installer c'est là
que ça peut devenir un problème parce
qu'il peut faire une colonie du coup là
ce qu'il faut faire c'est appeler
dératiseurs qui vont évaluer la
situation et prendre la meilleure
décision par rapport à la situation
on pourrait se dire que la solution
serait d'exterminer le rat mais en fait
c'est un animal qui rend beaucoup de
services à l'être humain puisque
il est utile dans le traitement des
déchets il décontamine les eaux des
égouts en mangeant les déchets les
petits cadavres etc après d'un point de
vue sanitaire effectivement les rats ils
sont également porteurs de certaines
maladies donc du coup ils se souillent
aussi de leur déjections des lieux où
l'être humain vit donc du coup il faut
trouver un équilibre comme tout maillon
d'une chaîne alimentaire il vaut mieux
essayer de le réguler plutôt que de
l'exterminer
une femelle est mature sexuellement à
partir de 2 3 mois et elle va pouvoir
faire une centaine de bébés au cours de
sa vie donc on voit bien le problème de
la prolifération d'une espèce comme le
rat puisque très vite on passe de un
animal à plusieurs centaines voire
plusieurs milliers alors il y a
plusieurs choses qui peuvent réguler une
une colonie de rats il y a effectivement
les maladies qui vont se transmettre il
y a également un certain nombre de
prédateurs donc ça peut être par exemple
les chats en ville c'est bien pour ça
qu'on avait des chats à un moment donné
sur les bateaux et en ville et après au
sein d'une colonie ça se régule assez
vite parce que si l'accès de la
nourriture devient trop difficile où il
y a plus accès de nourriture disponibles
alors les rats sont capables de se
dévorer entre eux pour réguler leur
colonie
il existe des dizaines d'espèces de rats
mais les trois espèces les plus
répandues dans le monde sont Ratus Ratus
ou le rat noir le Ratus norvégicus aussi
appelé le rabrun ou le surmelo et Ratus
exulence ou rat polynésien et en ville
celui qu'on trouve le plus c'est le
rabbin
alors le rat est une espèce qui s'élève
plutôt bien chez soi c'est un animal qui
apprécie le contact avec l'être humain
ce qu'il faut faire attention c'est que
c'est une espèce sociale donc il faut
jamais l'élever tout seul parce que un
rack élevé tout seul il va déprimé donc
il faut avoir au moins deux rats en même
temps chez soi et il faut lui donner un
espace qui est suffisant pour qu'il
puisse explorer parce que le rat c'est
un animal qui est assez curieux donc si
il a pas un environnement à explorer et
qui change souvent il va s'ennuyer et
donc déprimer
certains individus au sein de la colonie
vont goûter certaines nouvelles
nourritures
pour vérifier si cette nourriture est
saine ou pas et si ce sera survit il va
transmettre museau à museau à son
congénère l'odeur de cette nourriture
pour qu'il puisse la retrouver Era est
une espèce sociale qui vit en colonie
donc c'est des animaux qui ont besoin
d'interagir les uns avec les autres donc
ils communiquent par le son il vocalise
beaucoup notamment en ultrason donc
l'humain ne les entend pas il communique
par les odeurs c'est à dire que c'est
des animaux qui sont très sensibles aux
odeurs et notamment aussi au phéromones
et communiquent également par leur
comportement par exemple quand un animal
est dominé il va se mettre sur le dos
pour
signifier à son partenaire que il se
soumet à lui d'une génération à l'autre
finalement il y a une sorte de
transmission qui peut se faire sur
certains lieux où il y a plus de
nourriture ou certains lieux où il y a
des grands dangers
donc du coup ça leur permet de de
d'éviter se mettre
inutilement en danger et de favoriser
leur survie
[Musique]